foreign
September meeting for the joint
legislative Health and Human Services
oversight committee I wish to thank
representative Jess Edwards for filling
in both in June and in the chair I was
at the CDC in Atlanta at the time and I
want to thank him for filling in as
clerk today and when he is ready would
you please
um call the roll
you know
knowing about half the people out there
they've done this job and they're being
foreign
Mr chair
um I here I don't happen to have a list
of the official members of this
committee to for me to do a roll call
so I I can recognize the people who are
sitting here but I'm a little bit at a
loss of the people who are not that
right okay okay all right
he's an alternate that's been promoted
for today
okay and then we have representative
McMahon
then we have uh senator
Rosenwald
and we have the chair which is
representative Pearson
and then we have me
for the record state your name please uh
Jess Edwards and we have a professor
representative saloway
and we have uh Bill Nelson
representative Nelson
and I believe we're missing missing
representative Marsh Marsh which is why
I'm doing this and uh Senator Guida
Marsh now do we count
Senator gaida is not going to be able to
comment Senator gray is somewhere else
in the building and he's already come
downstairs thank you and said he'll be
here when he can be so I told him he
won't have any fun until he's here so
technically on Senator gaida it's my
understanding he's resigned from the
Senate and if he's resigned from the
Senate then he's really just not even
missing he's he's resigned I don't know
that I was here yesterday
oh so I'm mistaken I thought he had
results we have a quorum thank you very
much approval of the draft minutes of
June 24th everybody should have those
they have been sent to us and you should
have hard copy in what's in front of you
if all of this is on Channel Nine this
I'm gonna give him about another minute
to read it over
Mr chair
um I would move to accept these minutes
um the chair is going to call on the
senator who's already offered but okay
now's a good time okay thank you I would
move the minutes of
August June 24th a second any further
discussion
all in favor
aye opposed thank you
DHHS commissioner updates
Deputy Commissioner Weaver associate
commissioner hen
you know as baffles me that red is on
the red light gives it away
you just had me today Deputy
Commissioner Lori Weber Mercer hen is
not here today in terms of updates since
the last time we met in June I believe
the request was to give an update a
brief update on Hampstead Hospital my I
believe also sysc so uh with Hampstead
Hospital we've been about three months
operating now
um we actually are calling at Hampstead
Hospital and residential treatment
facility so you may see the acronym
hhrtf Hampstead Hospital and residential
treatment facility one of the things
that we're trying to do with Hampstead
hopefully by the end of this year is to
create a prtf because we are acronym
happy
psychiatric Residential Treatment
Facility so that hospital will provide
inpatient care as well as a prtf which
is a step down from a patient care
within inpatient care underway
the transition to the
new ownership has been smooth we have
well path as our vendor welcome Recovery
Solutions is our vendor I'm pleased to
tell you that all of the HHS management
positions there were six of them have
been filled and I think everyone is
aware of how hard it is to recruit
positions these days so that is quite an
accomplishment how many of these are
carried over from the previous team
uh only one okay
only one so one out of six uh the
accreditation and reimbursement
processes remain on track
um they are having Workforce issues as
I've just talked about as everybody else
is
um obviously that is a limiting factor
in terms of of a bed Supply because we
only have so many staff however they
have a recruitment plan that they've
submitted to the state
um and that they're working diligently
on we also have a we made us the
department made a commitment to
to bid out after the first two years uh
for who would run the hospital with us
we are actually on track on time to
release that RFP probably this fall in
November part of the process prior to
that was to do a request for information
and working with our partners about what
would that look like what would make the
most sense for us for a model in running
the hospital pleased to tell you that we
had a robust response and that's going
to help us inform how we write that
request for proposals and structure the
hospital
what's your census presently
I believe I think the other day I think
we were at 37 but so you've moved from
some to quite a few we yes they it has
been increasing yes I can tell you that
and obviously we've had discharges and
Emissions happening on a regular basis
um one of the requests back in June was
to do a quarterly report for Hampstead
Hospital so it is Our intention
um to provide that to this committee
which would have detailed reports as we
do in some of our other updates and we
are aiming to do that starting in
November as our first report from
wellpath will be mid-october and we've
together
and give you your a robust uh review in
November at the November meeting I'm
assuming we have one in November
absolutely okay
we just don't know when right there's a
couple of holidays in there yeah and an
election and an election yes a little
busy
so in terms of Hampstead that's that's
the the level of overview I have today
for the update unless there are any
any questions about Hampstead Hospital
in particular
for the record I live less than a mile
from Hampstead Hospital and Hampstead is
any thing else from the commissioner's
office
yeah trigger question sure
thank you Mr chair thank you Ms Weaver
Center and um I I think as somebody who
interacted a great deal last legislative
session with others on the on the new
replacement I want to apologize to the
department because I think the
legislature has let you down
we were acting in good faith when we
said that we wanted to see it closed on
the 30th of March we had a parallel Bill
to describe the replacement and the key
aspect of that was the capacity of the
replacement and we just could not reach
agreement so we gave you nothing to go
on in terms of money to to plan and
design it and and so I I have a concern
about what one April looks like under
the current legislative environment
where you have to close it but we've
given you know where to replace the
facility so could could you could you
tell us about that
sure I I hope I don't see that day I
guess I would I would say that I think
it would be uh
a real problem come April 1st if we had
nowhere for the Youth that are there
currently
we can't just put the youth elsewhere as
many of you know those are some of our
most uh challenged youth in that
facility we can't just displace them to
a res provider if that was the case we
would have done that already we looking
at out-of-state placements other states
are just in the same predicament that
we're in so that potentially would mean
if depending on what the census was and
the profile of the population at that
time that those kids would be released
to situations that would probably not
benefit anyone
um and that would mean staff we you know
I I think it's really hard to keep
Staffing and keep morale and keep a
facility running with as it is now with
knowing that it may be closing
um so it would be a challenge all around
and I I don't think it would benefit
anyone
so may I
uh
sorry the term maybe you're avoiding it
intentionally but uh could you could you
tell me what the impact might be on
Public Safety if um if the current lack
of plan goes through
I would say there would be a definite
impact on Public Safety it's hard for me
to predict knowing who particularly
would be there at that time in March but
if that were to happen today I could
tell you that there would be public risk
for some of these youth to be placed in
situations that would be not only unsafe
for them but potentially for the
community as well
sure okay just uh just so that you know
I've submitted two bills to OLS one is
to extend the date Beyond 30 March and
try to get that fast tracked it would be
great if the department could take a
look at it and consider being advocates
for an extension
um I I I'm only extending it for three
months which I believe will be
inadequate but but it should be enough
to have the department come and tell us
what it really ought to be so that we
can do do the right thing and then a
parallel Bill uh I'm I'm reintroducing
the bill to Define what the sununu
replacement Center ought to look like
and I'm I'm putting in it since the
capacity issue was kind of the big deal
I'm I'm putting in the the draft up to
18.
with operational planning for 12 to 14.
so so you'll have the physical capacity
to to breathe if you have to but that
the long-term operational costs should
be pegged a little lower at the 12 to 14
range so that's that's my intent there's
lots of time to talk about it I just
thinking that we're going to have a
public safety problem if we continue as
we are I want to get these two bills
fast tracked and I'd appreciate the
support of the department and getting it
passed thank you we are ready to have
that conversation and
anything further on this particular
topic
anything further from the deputy yes
Senator thank you
um given that we've been talking about
the new news center I wonder
um
what you can tell us about the two
recent
incidents of
um the police having to come in and
quell some disturbances sure what I can
tell you is that
we have a combination of having a
Staffing crisis of not having the the
amount of staff that we really need to
be able to run the facility as well as
some of the toughest kids so it's almost
The Perfect Storm of uh happening here
where uh the need for staff is not is
not there so in times like that and this
is not unprecedented to the center we've
had to call in law enforcement in the
past it's been a long time since we've
had to do that but for the safety of the
the youth and for the safety of our
staff we will rely on that Resource as
we need to so I will tell you that what
happened wasn't anything out of the
ordinary that wouldn't happen in a
facility like that it's our limiting
factor is that with the amount of staff
that we had and the Acuity of the need
of the of the youth it creates a
situation where we don't have enough
staff to do a two-on-one or a one-on-one
or what have you we're really stretched
really thin in those moments we need we
need that extra support and I I will
also say that it is hard for 4 we just
talked about closing the facility it is
very hard to recruit staff to a place
where they think that it's going to be
closing I think there's a lot of people
that want to come and help and work but
that is overshadowing the facility for
sure
thank you I know that on the fiscal
committee we've recently approved some
funding to give you more staff have
those people not been hired or have
other people left we have the staff
isn't increased as you've requested yeah
unfortunately the staff has an increase
it's decreased we have had some
resignations uh just that took place a
little while ago we have more to come
those enhancements definitely help the
staff that are there recruiting staff I
just put out and I'll call to every
employee then the department yesterday
that has any experience in this field
would they be willing to come and work
some overtime when we have multiple
openings in any shift particularly on
the weekend we want to get all the help
that we can but even getting help
requires a training period that we've
tried to condense and be efficient but
people need to be trained I couldn't
just walk in there and say hey I'm going
to help you there needs to be some
training so we're looking under every
Rock asking every person that we can and
trying to recruit that way and we also
have a staffing agency that's helping us
as well but they're struggling with
recruitment as well
anything else on this topic
anything else for the Deputy
Commissioner no thank you anything else
from the Deputy Commissioner no thank
you anything for her
thank you for coming thank you
next item is a a new item that just came
onto the list this week discussion on
the establishment of a subcommittee to
review transparency issues with the New
Hampshire Board of Medicine within the
office of professional licensure and
certification representative Dr Jeffrey
soloway thank you Mr chairman uh Mr
chairman I'm going to be making a motion
and I'm going to State the motion at the
outset so the clerk will have an
opportunity to get it down and then I'll
state it again after I'm done so that he
can
once again hear my garbled presentation
and per get the words correct and the
motion is
that the chairman
establish a subcommittee
on transparency and Reporting
by the New Hampshire Board of Medicine
that the chairman appoint
such members of the subcommittee who
will gather testimony from public and
officials
investigate the operations of the Board
of Medicine
in comparison to such boards
as they functioned in other states
and report to the oversight committee
their recommendations for legislation as
needed if that's the title of your bill
could you make that into an acronym
[Laughter]
I'd like to give the committee the and
will require a second on that motion if
it is to be approved but I'd like to
give the committee and the public some
of the background if they have not
already encountered it please um please
do so uh be aware I'm sure that the
Boston Globe which is I I think a
paragon of virtue in the fourth estate
has a team called their Spotlight team
this Spotlight team has a long history
of deep investigation of issues of
concern to the public generally
and that Spotlight team has won Pulitzer
prizes for the quality of their work
they are to be respected for the
journalism and dare I say appreciated
in the last few days
they have begun to feature a story on a
malpractice investigation at a major
hospital here in the state
which involves
um the question of whether the New
Hampshire Board of Medicine
has been transparent in making available
to the public
a list of malpractice claims lodged
against a single practitioner at that
major Hospital
the
allegation in Spotlight news reporting
and again I'm being very careful to
state that this is an allegation
and that it is the job of the journalist
to raise issues and to alert the public
rather than to provide a testimony
that is perfectly documented we have
another obligation then the journalists
do
the spotlight team has alleged that our
Board of Medicine is 50th in the country
in transparency in reporting uh
malpractice claims and the resolution of
those claims
that news is going to be out among our
constituents
they are going to ask what our role as
legislators is in investigating the
place of the Board of Medicine in
regulating malpractice claims and making
them transparent
um and it is Our obligation as
legislators
to do our own investigation of the Board
of Medicine to be very careful about the
testimony that we take from
professionals and from the public
and that we consider whether we wish to
make to this committee any
recommendations for legislation to deal
with the issues that arise
in order to do this we require a
thoroughly professional subcommittee
that is willing to sit through the
testimony of the public and the
testimony of the professionals and to
sort through uh whether there is a
legislative solution required so with
that we have the motion here it comes
again Mr Clerk and I thank you for your
patience uh can I read to you what I
think I have and then and then you can
tell me how to fix it uh I I think your
motion is that the chair shall establish
a subcommittee to investigate the
transparency and Reporting by the New
Hampshire Board of Medicine and that he
should appoint members to that
subcommittee that will take testimony as
needed and compare and contrast our
approaches to other state standards and
develop a report
to uh from the committee with
recommendations for legislation
thank you Mr clerk that was quite
excellent you'll take that absolutely
okay I I should have screwed it up
because I don't ever want to do this
again
we're all short-handed we all serve
where we must may I ask a question of
the of uh representative please
um okay so just just for Clarity on the
scope of of this committee uh I I think
your your intent is to trigger
the subcommittee specifically because we
have an instance that's being reported
by the Boston Globe but your intent is
not for us to look into that one
instance what you're looking for is the
systemic approaches around the Board of
Medicine and their transparency
reporting is that correct that is
exactly correct representative and given
your personal Cassidy may I respectfully
request that you work closely on this
committee
that'll be the chair that's the chair's
choice of course representative soloway
I was Consulting with my colleague you
may have said but if not I'm going to
say there were no references on the New
Hampshire Board of Medicine to this
particular individual but there was
extensive reference on the Massachusetts
board
and yet we are talking about an events
that are allegedly taking place in New
Hampshire why would Massachusetts
have more information than our own state
is the trigger here uh Mr chairman if
you'll permit me I've carefully avoided
references to this particular case I've
been quite careful about that you have
and I wish to avoid that at all costs
yes you are correct as you typically are
Massachusetts did in fact report
all the instances that were relevant to
this particular case but I wish to avoid
any comment on the case whatsoever I
agree with that but my bringing it up is
to say that
raises the question of why was this not
reported here and it could have been
about any number of people on any number
of occasions on any number of issues
this is incidental
it's just compare contrast and it could
well be that there are statutes or laws
in New Hampshire that are preventing
them from doing this this could be an
overreaction to the days when too much
was disclosed so we're not prejudicing
the board of medicines guilt or laziness
or anything we're just asking these
questions in general
we are asking questions about the
function of the board in general
I had a conversation earlier this week
with Lindsay Courtney JD executive
director of The Office of professional
licensure and certification
afterwards known as oplc and they
provide administrative support to over
40 Professional Licensing Boards of
which the Board of Medicine is one
and there is signed into law what was
Senate Bill 330 which establishes a
committee it's functioning presently I
believe under Senator Carson in the
chair it was formed it is meeting to
review the structure of Licensing and
the relationship with the office and the
boards
to make recommendations with a final
report due November 1st I asked
um
the director if that might make what
you're muting uh unnecessary and she
said absolutely not that we are doing a
microcosmic thing she is doing a macro
Cosmic thing and she would welcome and
she hopes the SB 330 committee would
welcome anything that we generate early
on particularly
um
so she says very much this would be a
good idea that we go forward with this
it would not over it would overlap but
it would not um be inappropriate given
the SB 330
the group Mr chairman to move forward we
will need a second I know that and then
of course it will be your prerogative to
recruit uh committee should the motion
pass before we vote on it uh Mr Ester
house uh from oplc is here and if you
want to come up to the chair and make
the microphone red
yeah
in case there's any input you'd like to
give us and answer any questions we
might have for clarity or is this being
recorded is this a is a video going to
be available later
do you know usually do we know it's
recorded I don't believe the fourth
floor gal is here and I don't see a
substitute all right so I'm sorry for
the interrupted I'm just sure that's
fine
good morning my name is douglasoster I
am general counsel for oplc and I
believe what you said is correct we had
a conversation earlier about that the
subcommittee 330 has been meeting
they're having their third meeting next
Wednesday and we are going over a number
of things fee structures
responsibilities between the boards
between oplc and one of the things we
are taking a look at is uh is the
hearing processed adjudication those
kind of things in the state and
as you pointed out what we're looking at
is I believe the number is 54 boards
that may change by the time I get back
to the office
um sort of the structure of of
everything on the whole we aren't
necessarily taking a look or doing a
deep dive on any particular board but it
does mean we are looking at every board
which lines up with what you said I
believe Mr chair I I didn't get the name
and do you have a do you have a business
card do you have a business card if you
just gave me the business card that
would be better I get dyslexic when I
listen I'll take one too while you're up
excuse me I'll take a business card too
thank you Mr chairman I just had a
question and I'm just trying to clarify
in my mind is this a creation of a
subcommittee of this committee to work
in conjunction with the committee
established by SB 330. this will be a
subcommittee of this oversight board to
work on its own but be
in contact with SB 330. sharing work
product at least from us to them and
hopefully them to us and
but that's not an official appointment
that is what I expect this group to do
and the reason to do that I'm just
thinking about redundancy of efforts you
know is in the rationale to do that is
my question I guess
the conversation I had with director
Courtney indicates what we're trying to
do is microcosmic they're trying to do
macro they're not going to do a dive
into a particular board but the general
interface between boards and them we are
doing a deep dive into one particular
thing there will be overlap
but it will not be
duplication or
okay
on this subject either of uh counselor
or
representative Solway on this topic
and any further discussion represent
Senators
um Mr chair I'm going to recuse myself
from this vote for reason that you've
then the clerk may call the roll
uh thank you Mr chair I'm I'm going to
make up the order uh representative
Murphy uh yes yes
uh representative McMahon yes
our Senator Rosenwald Marquis where
accuse and
uh
uh Mr chair oh the I'm going to go with
you late last
um Edwards uh votes uh yes
uh salloway yes
Sally is a yes uh Nelson as a yes uh Mr
chair yes is a yes uh that's one two
three six zero one five five to zero
with one recusal
no no I skipped you I didn't no six I
didn't write your name down
so so it's six six to nothing with one
or two uh recusal
I would welcome anyone from this
committee who wishes to serve on that
with
I'm making the final determination over
the weekend who will actually be on it
but if you're interested in it let me
know and we'll talk about it
and the Mover of the uh the maker of the
motion has given me a list of some
suggested people and we can talk further
over lunch which might make it tax
thank you
while the commissioner is here could
could I ask her back I have a couple of
questions I would ask if I were normally
just sitting here but the notes threw me
off I I have two uh spontaneous surprise
questions with the chairs leave you may
uh one for the chair please oh maybe I
should have left yeah yeah so but so so
I realize these are surprise questions
so I I I I'll I'll take with a grain of
salt anything you have to share with us
but
um
I'm sure you're you're aware of the
closed-loop referral system and the
legislature's concern about the closed
loop referral system over the last I
don't know a year or whatever and so
could you do you know
um what the status of the closed loop
referral system
Contracting process is and what sort of
timeline you might be on uh reviewing
and accepting bids
I can find that out for you I don't have
that with me at my fingertips right now
I I'm not surprised but it would be
great to just get um some insight to
where we are with the closed loop
referral system
and then I have a second question and
for the clerk please jot down anytime
any of us ask of anyone for further
information and who that person is
promising to get it back to us at some
point put that on your minutes please
all right and since I'm the acting clerk
you'd get it to me and I'll distribute
to the rest of the committee
um second question
Mr chair go ahead okay uh last week uh
during the fiscal committee uh there was
a little over I'm sorry there was a
little over six million dollars that was
accepted in federal funds to fund
um mobile Vans to go throughout the
state and provide vaccines and um
coveted vaccines and the the demographic
that was called out specifically there
were probably others that would also
receive it but the ones that were called
out specifically were children under the
age of five to receive their first shot
and kids over the age of five for for
boosters and that and the fiscal
committee approved at eight to nothing
the executive committee approved it and
so the monies come and the program's
going but what we asked the director of
Public Health
was to have and I I don't know his title
Dr Chan to have Dr Chan uh
provide a public-facing document
that states his assessment of the
quality of the research and the science
that would deal with
providing injections like vaccines to
otherwise healthy kids and to paraphrase
the director of Public Health she said
that she was unsure what that would look
like and that she would think about it
and it's and it's been a week and so I
would just I'm just curious on a
follow-up what is Dr Chan's
public-facing statement going to look
like how will it be made available to
the public
sure thank you for the question this is
Anne Landry associate commissioner that
oversees Public Health
good morning state your name again
please sure good morning Ann Landry
associate commissioner for Department of
Health and Human Services
um thank you so much for your question
representative Edwards and I may not be
answering it in the way that you want
but a director Tilly has been out on a
family matter since last since Saturday
and so while she's working as much as
she can that hasn't been the focus of
this week's work just given everything
else as you know that's going on in in
the division of Public Health Services
however I can commit to you that this is
on our radar we've engaged with Dr
Ballard and with Dr Chan and we will
think about as director Tilly see did
the best format for how we may do that
and work with our Communications
Department
um on how we'll present that so it
hasn't fallen off our radar but I
apologize it just hasn't been able to be
a priority with her out on a family
matter
so as as I I professionally I can accept
that answer I think that makes sense I I
hope in this Tilly's situation resolves
rapidly and positively I I I just think
that there's a group of our public
who has heard the phrase follow the
science for a very long time and would
like to be informed what the scientific
assessment is that's driving our policy
and particularly with with people being
particularly defensive about their
children I think this is an opportunity
for us to
communicate that New Hampshire has
investigated the science and that making
these vaccines available to the this age
group is medically appropriate we're not
I don't I I don't want to prejudge Dr
Ballard and Dr chance assessment of the
research but I I think we owe it to the
public to to communicate otherwise it's
the state is essentially uh warranting
to the parents that we've done our
homework it's all good and and frankly I
I've not done my homework on this and so
I need the smart guys to smart people to
figure it out so I'm understood and
while I I don't want to speak for Dr
Chan or Dr Ballard who's more than
welcome to speak I I will promise you
that we heard the request and I and
agree that it will be a great
opportunity to share with the public the
science and the scientific articles for
which Ben or excuse me Dr Chan has
reviewed but we really want to make sure
that it's presented in a digestible
method given I mean some of these
articles are very complicated I think
one of the ideas was to present a
summary on this Cliff Notes if you will
of the different articles so we're just
looking at the best best format so I
appreciate that and that's that's why
I'm asking the smart people to do that
but I think the opportunity to enhance
the high level of credibility the
department already enjoys is is there if
we can begin to have those conversations
about here's the science therefore that
this policy makes sense absolutely all
right thank you thank you very much the
chair will add the fact that in my four
days at the CDC in June with 39 other
legislators from around the country when
they asked us for feedback and input
that was something we said and they
acknowledged
they hadn't done that to the degree that
would have been helpful now I think a
lot of what they did was incredible but
we can always make it better and in the
recent statement from their director
saying there will be some changes at the
CDC they took that and a number of the
suggestions we inputted to them in June
so this is just making it home here and
I know that'll come when you will be
ready with a report that will really
give the information people want so
thank you so much Dr Ballard you want to
add
foreign
good morning for the record my name is
Dr Jonathan Ballard I work as the chief
medical officer of the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
I just want to express our gratitude for
putting forth this question
taking a step back each time information
recommendations come up from the CDC or
other federal health agencies we always
take a in-depth look at it we look at
the science behind the recommendations
not only the recommendation before we
you know agree to it ourselves there's a
number of professionals Dr Chan being
one of them that that often looks at the
met at the recommendations the science
behind each step we've done this that in
this case we do have
a great deal of of information that we
can put forth and plan to share publicly
um that would support that
recommendation
for this particular uh initiative to do
vaccination however
what we're recognizing is that there
will be considerable constraints upon
the Health Care system
at the same time where there will be
um you know
cases of Cobia 19 but also the workforce
shortage and then the need for increased
workers to do vaccine Administration
whether it's in the pharmacy setting the
primary care setting or elsewhere so
there
but what that initiative will do is
essentially add some capacity some
breathing room for our health care
infrastructure to do all of this work
this fall at the same time including
vaccinations for flu which we encourage
individuals to get we note that there
was an increase in flu activity this
past
winter in Australia summer here which
has been a good indicator in past years
of whether or not we'll have increased
flu season here so taking all that into
account with that Initiative for vaccine
accessed as its increased capacity for
those the persons particularly parents
who have any questions about their
childhood their children's vaccination
or health in general you know these
sites public sites probably would not be
the location for them it would be their
trusted Healthcare professional in the
in the office and that's what we want to
emphasize is what we're not sending
parents and children to get information
from and and vaccination necessarily
from a public site if they have any
questions like that there are questions
about the science what's right for my
individual child is between you your
child and your health care provider and
we want to keep that being the um the
situation being married to a trusted
health care provider I would agree
that's how it works yes
so I absolutely agree patients provide a
relationship is the dominant one the the
reason I'm distinguishing this
initiative is because it's Federal money
that the state approved and so a bunch
of Finance Geeks said that you could go
ahead and spend your money on this and
so because we're putting our thumbprint
on on and effectively approving it it
would just be great if the state had a
position and if the primary channel of
communications was to the providers that
would be fine I'm not I wouldn't
prejudge how the information gets
distributed I just recognize I think we
have an obligation
um
follow up okay and you probably heard
that Denmark is uh just very recently
suspended all requirements for vaccines
for all of the population 50 and younger
so
um so I I don't want to expand the scope
of what you're looking at but it's those
kinds of things that are out in the
public that triggers more fear
uncertainty and doubt about what our
public policy is if the if the nation of
Denmark can say no no more for anyone
under 50. so
thank you very much
thank you
that was the last one
that was your last one I'm going back to
my script okay
like this
task force on Precision medicine and
biomarker testing status update you
heard a report on this in June this
subcommittee this representative Rogers
subcommittee was not voted into
existence but as a committee that will
not just meet a couple of times but meet
I believe quite a long time and do great
work it would be good devoted into being
representative soloway thank you Mr
chairman
um for those of you who are interested
whose paper recycle bin is not yet full
there are copies of the report on
Precision medicine here at the table uh
if you have not received one in the past
at the past meeting or the meeting
before that please feel free to pick one
up
um the we refer to this as the Catherine
Rogers commission
and as uh excuse me what does it look
like because I haven't found mine yet
and have you found your coffee was
distributed like two meetings ago
okay
we may continue please
um oh we just need a motion which I will
make Mr chairman uh that the uh chairman
uh appoint and approve uh the
subcommittee on Precision medicine and
that he be asked to appoint an
appropriate committee to fulfill the
um goals of HB 1290 FN as set out in
this report
and I believe sir that that is simply a
housekeeping matter and we can go on
there is the motion
do I have a second
yeah clarify them up yeah clarify them
find the motion please so I I trailed
off when you were talking about the
reporting is there one report or a
series of reports that are anticipated
I'm hoping that there will be one report
and it will be uh a delivered
expeditiously I'm hoping to have this
wrapped up by November oh thank you
thank you
the motion before us to
authorize the chair to appoint a
subcommittee
that is the task force on Precision
medicine I still need a second
representative Nelson for a second any
the clerk may call the roll
thank you Mr chair uh representative
Murphy yes
uh representative McMahon
Senator Rosenwald
uh clerk votes yes
uh representative saloway yes
um chair votes yes so that's seven
nothing passing and once again as with
the previous motion if there's anyone on
the committee who would like to serve on
it please let me know in a day or so or
before we leave and
we will be putting representative Solway
and I will be putting this committee
together over the weekend so that it can
get going
thank you for this
that works
next item on the agenda House Bill 1439
relative to Health Care Facility
visitation policy status updates Mr
Stephen Annan president of the New
Hampshire Hospital Association Paula
minahan Senior vice president state
government relations of the New
Hampshire Hospital Association
if you have business cards I'd love one
at the end sure
good morning uh Mr chairman members
committee for the record Steve Onan
president of the New Hampshire Hospital
Association Paula menahan Senior vice
president state government relations
Hospital Association we will get you
um business cards
so again thank you for the opportunity
to come back to the committee to provide
an update I want to thank you Mr
chairman and other members who were part
of the development of House Bill 1439
the bill that was being heard during a
very challenging time
um during the Omicron surge earlier this
year
um you know I would say hospitals
never want to restrict visitation for
their patients they
did early on in the pandemic frankly at
the urging and request of federal and
and and local Health officials because
of the nature of the virus and really
the unknown uh factors that we had
um the lack of PPE the lack of
vaccination and all and all of that
um
over the summer of 2020 those began to
we worked with the commissioner and the
department to really open up um
Healthcare to open up uh visitation
um and unfortunately we saw yet again
another surge
um but let's be clear hospitals do not
want to restrict visitation it's an
important part of the the healing
process but they have to do sometimes
they have to to protect the the health
of the patients uh the staff and and
visitors
um as as you know this provision was
moved into the patient's Bill of Rights
which is a place where we thought that
it really belonged and we've been
working with our hospitals over the
summer to understand how they're making
the the their visitation policies known
to to patients and to families and
following through on working to ensure
that patients are able to have visitors
when they they come to the hospital
um whether that's in the emergency room
whether that's in the patient units or
whether that's frankly in the practices
that they that they run and we're very
pleased to say that you know hospitals
continue to work very hard to open up
those facilities to make certain that
patients can have
um visitors um while they are in their
care
um Paula I'll turn it over to Paul and
ask her to summarize a few key points um
in terms of the work that we've been
doing over the summer with our members
thank you Steve so thank you chairman
Pearson and others for your support on
this bill and your continued involvement
during the committee of conference and
when this bill was finalized in the
committee of conference there was
discussion and requests that we come
back to this Committee in September to
update you on a couple things one was
discuss relative to how the hospitals
are making patients aware of their
visitation policies in addition to
posting on their website which they all
do have always have done for a long time
but in addition to that what are they
doing so I've been working with the
hospitals and they are well aware of the
law reviewing their policies as we speak
to ensure that patients and visitors are
aware of Hospital visitation policies
and the procedures in in a variety of
ways I think this points to the fact
that and what we testified on through
last session was that hospitals need and
require flexibility to ensure that the
guides written materials are not
outdated and that they are um they have
variations on how they are communicating
with their patients so on this request
um there was a variety of responses some
do include the Hospital visitation
policies in their admission packets some
post it all in patient and visitor
entrances some and provide them in the
inpatient and emergency room materials
and some have a general patient resource
guide
and some post them throughout the
hospital so my point is just that it
there is a variety of ways that they are
communicating a lot of them are looking
at their current processes and updating
them but I am reminded by a number of
folks that have worked in hospitals that
now work here with us at the association
and Foundation that by by
these policies change so much those pack
packets are when they update them they
to change that up the chances of having
errors and having Incorrect and outdated
materials is really a problem that they
trying to avoid because they want to
communicate as best they can with their
patients so that one that it is it
there's a variety of them but uh as far
as how they communicate so I just that's
showing that they need flexibility the
other request was how are hospitals
informing patients or their
representatives in the case of a denial
or revocation of visitation rights
so um that is again a variety of ways
but it is either by the nurse manager or
the unit manager supervisor on the floor
um and that would be probably to the
patient and then the or or the
representative and or it sometimes
happens through security staff again it
they do it it just it there's a variety
of ways in which they communicate
the revocation it does not happen often
as um as you would as you would think so
it it that is but that is the variety of
ways that the hospitals deal with that
the other question had to do with how is
this documented because again this was
all debated during the course of of
House Bill 1439. how is this documented
um some documented in the EMR if it's a
patient
um issue and some documented in what is
they consider a security log and that
would be for a non-non-patient or
visitor because there's no EMR when it
comes to a non-patient um or yeah
visitor sometimes there's a letter that
ends up being scanned in the in the EMR
and sometimes it's in the nurse's notes
again a variety of ways that they are
documenting
the fourth question was how do hospitals
make patients aware of the patient Bill
of Rights this was pretty uniform
because they have been communicating
Patient Bill of Rights for a very long
time in addition to being on their
website they do have those in the in the
admissions packet so that was a
consistent
um Universal response some have what
they call brochures as well as admission
packets but others say they have packets
handouts signage internet
um all of the above so um what I do want
to point out though is the the patient
Bill of Rights has not actually been
updated by legislative Services yet and
my understanding is it could be even
though the the law is in effect the bill
the patient Bill of Rights has not been
updated there actually was another bill
that actually changed the patient bill
right so they're they legislative
Services
um I think it takes up to possibly six
months I'm not sure
um before they update it and then once
they do that then and the hospitals will
update their their documentation but
they are waiting for the state to
actually update the patient Bill of
Rights right now which there actually is
a provision that allows the hospitals to
have that flexibility waiting for the
laws actually to be updated so I just
wanted to point that out because they're
not if you look at the RSA there it is
not updated yet it's the last update was
2021.
I have an unrelated question when you're
ready let's have related questions first
yeah
yes
oh there it is
hello Madam minahan hello representative
and Mr President of course uh to clarify
a continuity and just suggest on my bias
on all the work you've done on that you
all are doing is yet to be a Common
Language and the patient Bill of Rights
that would be then adhered to by all our
Medical Services uh hospitals in the
state of New Hampshire
um House Bill 1439 does not dictate what
the language is it just um requires them
to have their policies
um updated policies on their website
um that's what the the law says so to
ensure and to ensure that also um that
they always have a caregiver allowed
into the facility when appropriate if
it's not appropriate then they have to
document why it would not be allowed so
it doesn't it's not prescriptive as far
as what is included in the policies is
that am I answering your question okay
that's the yes I mean that's the half of
it just the class I know in the on my
first happened in my mind here was then
the Common Ground would be the patient
Bill of Rights would be in all of our
hospitals
modality of operation but in terms of
specific application for The Unique um
facilities and how they do things that's
where these other other criteria would
play a role that still needs to be
clarif clarified and confirmed
so you're right the patient Bill of
Rights as the original Bill did not have
um this this language of the law in the
patient Bill of Rights we believed
because this really is a patient issue
we wanted we thought it made more sense
to be in the patient Bill of Rights
because the hospitals currently and
continue to post on their website and
make the patient Bill of Rights that is
unique to New Hampshire in the admission
package so it's much more widely
distributed so the new language that
comes out of the law will be in the
patient Bill of Rights so then that is
to get into the the interpretive legal
appeal to come once maybe on some of
these issues is uh relative to 1439 I
don't have it in front of me at the
moment but it would meet the the intent
of 1439 and what you just said is
happening outside of making the specific
facility might have just have maybe
different access rules just on the type
of services being provided
I I think yes I agree with that
statement yeah okay I want to make sure
you know I read what you write so okay
thank you very much you're welcome
This Is Us liberal arts somewhat
ill-defined thought and I'm good at that
you as you know
um
with different hospitals
doing
is I I can see where that would be an
advantage you tailor it made to who you
are your community and all of that
I can also see there's many
disadvantages in that well my cousin who
went to the hospital over there this is
what they did on that and I don't see
that around here yeah
[Music]
discuss
I think what we what we've always said
is you know each individual Hospital
needs to
um follow the patient's Bill of Rights
and to do what is in the best interest
of their patients um and to do so in in
ways that meet the the letter and the
and the intent of of what we're trying
to do
um so giving them that flexibility we
believe is is is appropriate and
important
um at the we also again as Paula noted
you know continue to work with our
hospitals share policies of what others
are doing so that you know we can try
and help others understand what their
colleagues are doing and and over time
um you know we'll likely create a little
bit more consistency but again at the
end of the day you know each individual
institution needs to fulfill its mission
to its patients and its community and
giving them that flexibility to do so
within the the spirit of the patient's
Bill of Rights we believe is is entirely
appropriate the small family practice
facility I'm part-time CEO of does it
about that way too we want to see what's
best for us but I do talk to my
counterparts at other places and we swap
information and sometimes we wind up
learning from each other and that sounds
like what you're doing it's exactly what
we're doing yes and thank you um but yes
I should have mentioned that that they
do share where they're what their
current policies are and as Steve said
last year their policies change I know
one hospital had policies changing every
week for a while because during The
Surge which makes it really really
challenging for all including obviously
folks coming into the facility so but
yes they do share along
um amongst each other all sorts of
different um what policies that they
have and then they bring them back to
their committees that they have
internally which I'm sure you're
familiar with that that structure and
then they do debate and discuss and
again based on the number of individuals
maybe at the time that have covid that
are in their facilities
and then what the burden is relative to
that as well as the Staffing challenges
that they have they may have a more
restrictive policy at one facility
versus one that's across the way
um or across across town
um so but that is kind of the these
challenges that they're facing right now
so I appreciate your comment and I will
take that back to our hospitals to again
to continue having these discussions and
to appreciate exactly what you just said
that folks
visit a number of facilities throughout
the throughout the state and they're
going to see different potentially
different policies and to understand why
that is
when we first
when it first hit us
when my staff thought that they had
adequately communicated through the
various ways we communicate with our
patients
adequately communicated what we were
doing and why
I said I think this needs to be doubled
if not tripled we need to say it again
and again and again we need to
make sure that it's written at the
non-technical level I mean I looked at a
document that was brilliant and if you
were teaching nursing it would have been
fantastic but this is going to our
patients who are not bad people and
they're not stupid people but they're
not technically medical people so we
made sure that when we thought they knew
it we told them again and when it was
changing we told them that and in our
opinion why
Mr chairman I think one of the strengths
of the hospital system here in New
Hampshire is the work that we do through
the hospital Association through our
foundation for all the communities you
know we bring together
um you know the professionals um whether
it's the HR whether it's the nurses the
doctors the others and and and we do we
share best practices and we learn from
one another and I I would say you know
one of the Hallmarks of uh my time here
um I came from the American Hospital
Association where I saw hospitals and
associations across the country and I
would say one of the things that that I
believe truly is a Hallmark of what we
do here in New Hampshire is that we work
together and we there's an expectation
that we're going to work together and
collaborate
um certainly something we saw uh on full
display during the pandemic
um but I think it's it's truly what
defines how we how we do our work
together and so we'll continue to share
we'll continue to learn from one another
and we'll use these opportunities to
make to make that uh make that happen
and with the Miss minahan regular ready
to wipe down the microphone thank you so
much for coming unless you have another
one okay I'll hold hold that um all
right
um hold your moist Tower left please
representative Edwards well I think uh
representative Murphy's being discreet
with his finger over here you may have a
question not a question but maybe a
clarification and I was trying to think
of a rationale why different hospitals
do things differently
the patient Bill of Right is a uniform
Testament that all hospitals have but if
you I was trying to think of an example
that might be helpful to understand why
they could be different in different
hospitals you could have the same
diagnosis you know specific say cancer
diagnosis and in one hospital it may be
an infusion Suite that has a certain
amount of accessibility by the public in
by Family whereas you may be with the
same diagnosis in a more acute setting
like a tertiary care hospital that needs
you know PPE and gowns and no visitation
at all so you could carry the same
diagnosis but you do need to have
variations in the way you treat
visitation in other opportunities for
family and others to visit with patients
thank you Dr Murphy any response to that
I mean yeah amen sounds good
that's a statement to start I am not
running for re-election so this is not
an election question at all but a
statement that somewhat follows what
you're saying
I live near frisbee Hospital
frisbee Hospital in my opinion
is a disaster at the moment that is my
opinion
I have mentioned before it it's public
note on knowledge in all the newspapers
that it's really going downhill
they have lost approximately 20 doctors
several fired the rest have decided to
quit
or retire
Hospital services are declining I know
that personally from the the latest
being the maternity services
a delay in getting images
test results and appears to be related
to staffing issues
ER patients are often not seen because
they do not have somebody to read an
x-ray or a test
I have recently been there for a test
this sounds silly and see a full parking
lot go in the hospital there's nobody
there so I'm sort of suspicious how the
cars appear but it's only an observation
as a result of this patients need to
seek Services elsewhere that messes it
up down the line because everybody like
myself or moving the other two get
doctors at other places and that delays
the receiving of doctors are overwhelmed
and more than not are not taking on new
patients or extremely long wait this is
not being done In fairness to the
current patients if you are lucky to
find someone you are appointed to
typically your appointments typically
months away I'm very concerned about
this it affects the elderly affects the
people I would guess if we had a hearing
on this issue when we held it over in
Rochester area you'd have a room full of
people I would guess that 75 percent of
the people that use those services are
Furious
nothing against private ownership the
way it is going I personally asked I was
down there for a test a week and a half
ago for to talk to an administrator
someone came out and said they'll give
you a call while I'm still waiting no
response I'm really beginning to concern
the quality that some places
provide I've talked to doctors off the
Record I've talked to people who work
um in other ways with a hospital I've
talked off the record with employees
100 everybody says they've got a big
problem
employees are overworked especially
those who are just taking telephone
calls simple things and they're being
they'll use with work
and I'm just really concerned and I need
to I'm sorry I brought this up here but
it is something that the people in that
area need to find out what's happening I
totally know Mr chairman that there's a
shortage Statewide I do not deny that
but it's a tsunami effect at frisbee
hospital and I think it affects all the
area hospitals that everybody now
including myself have to move to doctors
because my primary doctor just I just
received a note that he's no longer
going to be there at the end of
September and there's one more to add to
the list I'm sorry to sound off but it
just affects me and thank you I'm a
small morning hand for helping me on
another issue thank you
first appreciate the comments um
obviously I can't speak to your
individual situation
um I do know that um you know they
continue to to look to bring in
additional clinicians that's something
that's ongoing that that work
um you know the the workforce shortage
is absolutely very very real
um uh something we've been you know
chronicling over the last uh several
months we actually just released a
report
um last week
um hospitals in New Hampshire saw
133 percent increase in the cost of
outside labor contract labor so the need
to bring in Travelers nurses other
therapists uh other uh locums uh you
know providers to provide care to make
certain that there are doctors in the
emergency room that there are doctors
and nurses to care for patients um in
the hospital that is simply not a
sustainable Trend and it's something
that we certainly are going to be
working very very hard and through to
try and make certain that we can make
some progress but you know as I've been
saying since the beginning of the
pandemic we're going to need help to to
get through this um and you know we're
not through yet to the other side
completely
um and um the next you know 12 to 24
months I think are going to be some of
them more challenging
um yet
um and it's really around you know
Workforce and then you know Financial
sustainability which is really uh the
other side of the same coin Mr Annan
have you found that since the costs of
bringing in Travelers really is
increasing your budget the insurance
companies are rushing to up their
reimbursements to the hospitals
I have not heard that Mr chairman
didn't happen to us either
representative Edwards this for
representative Nelson it looked to me
like you were maybe reading off of some
notes do you want me to include those
notes in the minutes so that we uh
because I didn't do a very good job of
recording all your concerns
clean up what I wrote on here first
thing please take out the swear words
[Laughter]
anyone else I I am representative
Edwards and maybe maybe this is uh this
is either to
um the witnesses or to uh the commit the
commissioner but
um
do we have a form I imagine we must have
a formal process within DHHS or
somewhere that if things get really bad
at a given institution that we decertify
them for uh patient care do we do we
have a break glass way of
decertification of a facility and and
should we have one
I would say
um I don't know the terminology that
you're using but obviously um there are
Health Facilities licensing
um uh all of the critical access
hospitals this 13
rural small hospitals uh are certified
through state survey and certification
the other larger hospitals tend to use
um another accrediting agency
such as the Joint Commission or dnv that
accredits them
um so the they they do that under the
federal CMS rules that allow them to to
be accredited to serve Medicare Medicaid
patients the state does license those
facilities
um so if that answers the question of
how that's right and those are the Hep
802 rules are the licensing rules and
they're pretty specific relative to what
the hospitals are required to make
maintain and administer in order to be
licensed which is an annual process so I
think it is a question for health
facilities under DHHS if to get more
specific but that that's our response
so I think that was 90 of the answer and
I apologize for not using the proper
semantics earlier but um so and so it
just leaves in my mind the the question
of process whether or not there is a
process available to uh to to pull a
credential or to remove a license and if
that is an ongoing process or if that
has to be an ad hoc
action by the department because they've
become aware of a problem right so it's
a process question and I don't know if
you can answer that or if the
I think it'd be best answered by the
department
and I'm not suggesting it needs to
happen but just hearing uh the concerns
of Representative Nelson it just
triggers in my mind do do we have a
viability ongoing viability test to uh
withdraw a license if it should have
become necessary
and I I see the consultation back there
no no do you do you have anything you
want to say about and whether or not
there's an ongoing process or a Nimble
ad hoc process to withdraw a license
okay
I had another one for you
just I'm the Medicaid director but also
a former Hospital executive I think that
the the survey and certification process
um is both a process and an incident for
example if there was a complaint
registered by someone made a complaint
to the department it could either be
picked up under the Medicare Medicaid
certification process or under a
licensure process
and so it could be as a result of a
survey or it could be a result of a
reporting of an incident and I think we
could if you have more detailed
questions I think the person who
oversees that function for the
Department would be better to answer
your answer you specifically
I'm at a high level yes or no and what I
heard I heard just heard you say is yes
there is a a Nimble process that if
necessary action can be taken to remove
a license from a health facility yes I
think that it goes through a process
before that would happen so for example
if they couldn't provide
um you know
oxygen or or water to be able to provide
care that might result in something but
to go to immediacy of removing a license
that's a that doesn't happen it's more
of a process
thank you
I was among the various conferences I
was sent to this summer one was on Rural
medicine where they faced the small
Hospital issues and this is all over the
country
shortages of staff and various creative
ways to see what one can do to alleviate
that and I might be interested
been a month or two a little report from
the Department indicating
what commissioner shibanet had shared
with me some time ago that there are
various issues various plans being
looked at on how do we improve
Workforce and she was sharing some
interesting thoughts and it was
wonderful and it'd be nice to get some
update in a month or two on what are we
doing positive because there's no doubt
that representative Nelson's story is
being told all over the country
and it's it's it's difficult to be the
patient I would guess it's at least as
difficult to be the providers who are
trying to do their best representative
Solway but thank you Mr chairman
um
we are facing a
multi-pronged tsunami in healthcare
we have been unable to staff our
hospitals with nursing staff
even here in New Hampshire some of our
Premier Health Care institutions are
staffed by and large with lnas rather
than RNs and as a result we rely on
Travelers
um several concomitants uh wait times
for uh results wait times for
appointments have become
unconscionable putting patients at risk
at the same time Mr chairman we have the
Advent of a number of new uh pathogens
in our hospitals that we are having a
great deal of difficulty managing and
our rates of infection are being driven
by new pathogens and
Staffing by professionals who are not as
Adept at controlling infections as we
might hope
uh this is a coming crisis uh that each
of us is going to feel individually
and it is imperative that we find ways
here in Buffalo New Hampshire to
innovate our ways through this coming
tsunami
and it may be the purview of this
committee to participate in that process
I'm going to cut off discussion on this
topic and give Mr Allen the last word on
it before we move on to the next agenda
item I think uh no no no go ahead
Mr chairman I just want to say thank you
uh to the committee for the opportunity
to come back and share with you we're
always willing and happy to do so
um we appreciate the the input we
appreciate your uh support for the work
that that our members are doing
um and represent Nelson will certainly
follow up um with you on that question
and representative Edwards I'd be happy
to meet with you privately to respond to
your unrelated question okay
thank you so much thank you New
Hampshire Health Care quality and safety
commission annual report
in keeping with our tradition here at
least one of the presenters must be
it's a requirement yes you think a word
shorter Workforce shortage is hard
specify they must be named Lori that
really
okay the chair now points himself acting
morning thank you for including us in
your presentations today uh my name is
Rory dos Diamond I'm the director at the
center of quality and safety at Southern
New Hampshire health and I'm the current
chair of the New Hampshire quality
Commission
and I'm the Laurie I'm Lori Underwood
I'm the chief operating officer at New
London Hospital and I am the past chair
of the New Hampshire Healthcare quality
and safety Commission
so you don't get a lorry as your new
chair but you do get an Ori of some sort
that's an acceptable variant thank you
so for a brief background of the
commission as a reminder we were
established by the legislature in June
of 2005 and it was to enable Health Care
Providers to share information about
adverse outcomes and prevention
strategies in a learning environment
which Fosters Candor and self-critical
Analysis while maintaining the
confidentiality of that information the
commission has evolved over the past 17
years to expand its scope we include
representation from each of the 26 acute
care hospitals in the state we have
added four specialty hospitals so that
includes two psychiatric hospitals and
two Rehabilitation hospitals and we also
now have representation from 20
freestanding Ambulatory Surgery
centers we also include three at-large
public members and a designee of the
commissioner of the Department of Health
and Human Services
the efforts of our commission are Guided
by four guiding principles which include
promoting High reliability organizations
establishing just cultures within our
organizations adopting evidence-based
best practices to improve outcomes and
incorporating the voice of the patient
so in some planar English let me cut in
for a minute to say that we do have a
written report that looks like this on
its cover so members we've got all of
this and can follow along with you we're
on page three thank you
uh so in some planner English promoting
High reliability organizations means
that we are proactively trying to put
processes and systems in place to reduce
the likelihood of harm or error
establishing just cultures means that we
are looking at our errors with an eye to
whether the error was produced by a
system issue or whether it was a result
of Reckless Behavior and that we are
approaching those errors with that in
mind evidence-based best practices I
like to say as we know better we do
better certainly the science evolves and
as we understand better things as we
have new technology to incorporate that
we do so and incorporating the voice of
the patient is rather self-explanatory
and I think having those three public
members on our commission has been
extremely helpful in giving us some of
that patient perspective as to how they
view the health care when they come into
so um I'd like to just walk through a
few of the highlights of our year this
past year which are outlined in the
document that um that you have in front
of you
um
let's start on page four starts on page
four
so I'm just going to choose a few of the
highlights to give a little uh
information about and certainly if you
have any questions at any time please
ask them
um so during our commission year we had
a total of five meetings
these meetings I was here about a year
ago presenting to you in the first year
of our covid response and I remember at
that time saying I really hoped that the
commission would be able to get back to
in-person meetings and unfortunately
with how things evolved through the year
we did not so our meetings continued to
be virtual through the year and I would
have to say one of the biggest pieces of
learning that we as Leaders of this
group have have achieved in the Years
how to run a virtual meeting with 50
people on the on the session it takes a
village to do that our discussion topics
and things that we spent a fair amount
of time on
particularly included our covid-19
response continuing to look at the
impact of the functioning of our
facilities and the many ways that these
were unprecedented In Our Lifetime as
Healthcare Providers and as support
providers in our organizations we saw
the highest number of cases beginning in
the at the beginning of the pandemic and
in the middle of this commission year
this really pushed hospitals Beyond its
capacity particularly in critical care
non-icu settings were transitioned to
accommodate the influx of patients and
daily bed meetings occurred at the state
level to maintain situational awareness
and facilitate Care at times during this
year there were no acute care or ICU
beds available in the entire State of
New Hampshire
patients were being transferred to the
nearest available appropriate bed and
that could have been in Boston
Springfield Portland Maine or sometimes
in Connecticut so this was a daily issue
that we were all dealing with and as the
commission we were talking about what
that meant and how we assured the safety
of patients in those times nurses
shifted to team nursing models we of
course ended up in the situation in
which we always did not have enough
nurses we couldn't get enough enough
Travelers and we did not have the
ability to say we can't take care of you
we had to figure out ways to do that
Dr Chan was present at all of our
commission meetings he kept us appraised
of covid related prevalence and
infection prevention strategies
including the vaccine rollout which
happened through the year we also
discussed the extended response of what
covid would mean to our organizations as
as it shifted to an endemic state which
is very slowly happening
we also spent a lot of time on patient
safety ongoing adverse event review
hospital-associated infections reviewing
best practices that were happening in
organizations across the state
also looking at fire safety one of our
topics was fire safety on the whole
Advent of vaping pens was a big issue
because of course there's no smoking in
a hospital but
um those people who many of whom were
using vaping pens didn't consider that
to be smoking and so that was something
that we needed to address as well
we also talked not just about the
problems but about the success stories
and refocusing on best best practices
and what what we talk about in the
healthcare Industries those bundles are
things that we can do every time to be
able to assure the best outcomes we also
had pretty high staff turnover and high
numbers of traveler staff and we needed
to identify these opportunities to
remind our staff of the existing tools
and best practices that were in place
during this time and I think we talked a
little earlier about the person who
picks up the phone being the one who
takes sometimes the brunt of the issues
we also dealt with schools closing a lot
of our younger employees not being able
to work because they were home schooling
their children so that fueled some of
the turnover that we um that we all felt
through throughout the state in
different ways
we talked at length about staffing
issues and what that impact was along
with the pandemic on not only our own
industry but other Industries around us
in our communities and those were were
very interesting conversations among all
of the different members
we tried to really talk about ways that
we could help our existing staff to not
leave that we could keep them that we
really wanted to keep our our existing
really awesome staff how we could help
them with learning more tools about
resilience how we could all be providing
them with good positive feedback about
their contributions to our patients care
and the the stories from across the
state were pretty amazing and many of us
were able to bring back new things to
our organizations that we may not have
thought about and that's really the
beauty of the commission and of coming
together is that we share fearlessly we
we and we steal from each other it's
actually mostly that we're willing to
give to each other and so I think that
has been the real benefit over all of
these years and I've personally been
involved with this commission for more
than 12 years
another challenge that our staff has has
faced over the last year that we've
talked about and the commission was
involved in a discussion at the
legislative legislative level is about
workplace safety and violence there's a
lot going on everybody's really
struggling with things that are going on
in our in our world right now
um in that we were
involved in the discussions
um
and active in the Senate Bill 459
legislative development by providing
testimony on our discussions and
regarding the impact of workplace
violence on Health Care settings and we
aided in the development of the New
Hampshire Healthcare workplace safety
commission that is currently being
established
when lastly one other area that we spent
a fair amount of time on was opioid
safety and certainly we all know what
has been going on in the world about
opioid safety and within the state we
are not immune from this we completed an
opioid safety best practice Gap analysis
to determine the current state of of
Affairs in all of our organizations and
you know like Rory said we're we're
quite a mixed bag of Ambulatory Surgery
centers hospitals and many of our most
of our hospitals have physician
practices so really looking at the
utilization of opioids across all of
those and what is the best practice
that's happening now we had some
presentations on enhanced recovery after
surgery since that's a pretty big area
in which opioids are used
and a lot of talk about what some very
Innovative practices that are happening
throughout the states
uh one of the things we started to talk
about and probably will be continuing
through this year is the impact of
Health inequities on the quality of
patient care so that is where people
live
um and all kinds of other
um
issues of Health Equity whether that be
education or language or age or ability
to pay and all of those things and
really trying to talk about how do we
assure that everyone is able to um to
access patient care regardless of all of
those things
so that was our last year it was a very
busy year we appreciate the support of
this
um this committee to can help allow us
to continue this work throughout the
state in a very protected way in that
protected way allows us to share in a
very open and honest
um and an honest way that can really
impact Improvement through the
organizations
and I wanted to give you a bit of a
preview of uh perhaps next year and we
have already started the next commission
year our four guiding principles remain
the same we have included some language
related to Health Equity and focusing on
that within those four guiding
principles
um we're going to continue our ongoing
discussions about the um Adverse Events
and adverse event reporting we are now
getting more current information from
the Department of Health and Human
Services about Statewide Trends which is
helping us to identify issues that we we
might want to bring for discussion to
the commission we will continue to
discuss Workforce shortage I don't think
that's going away anytime soon
unfortunately so it certainly has an
impact on Healthcare quality and patient
safety opioid best practices again will
continue our conversations about that we
also look at what's going on in the news
and we have conversations related to
those things recently there was the
finding in Tennessee where a nurse was
found criminally liable for a medication
error
um that's concerning to us from the
perspective that in order to improve
quality we need to know what those
errors are that are happening and we
need to know about near-misses maybe the
error didn't happen but it came close to
happening if we're not aware of that
it's really hard to get ahead of it and
put in those best practices to help
close the Swiss cheese as we say
um so that is one thing that we're
concerned about certainly drug diversion
has come up recently in the news that's
another concern in terms of not only
keeping our patients safe with opioids
but keeping our staff
um safe and going back to what Laurie
mentioned in the beginning that we have
been meeting via Zoom we are hoping this
year will be the year where we will be
able to start meeting in person again
we've managed to have a very robust
conversation in a virtual format however
there's really a lot to be said for the
community building the connections that
we make in that in-person setting the
relationships that we build the trust
that we build with our colleagues and
the power of being able to know those
faces those names and the the people
that you can pick up the phone and give
a call and say hey have you ever run
into this
how did you handle it what can we learn
from your experience
the chair has a question on page five
um bullet point three line three
um the violence against health care
workers is increasing uh do you see this
is a blip because of the
psychological pressure everybody is
under because of the pandemic or do you
see this is a trend that is continuing
even when the pandemic Ebbs
I'm hopeful that it's a trend related to
the pandemic
um I think part of the what the
commission has uncovered and we added
workplace violence reporting I don't
know how many years ago to the adverse
event reporting
um
so we have certainly seen an increase in
reporting and awareness and I think
sometimes that increases the awareness
that is happening it doesn't necessarily
mean that there is more violence but
certainly within the last couple of
years we have seen an increase in the
actual interactions that are negative
patients are waiting longer in emergency
departments that influences their
experience I think what we were speaking
about previously with limited visitors
that's had a major impact on what our
staff is dealing with with upset
patients is there anybody else from the
committee have a question for Lori and
Rory
I have a comment about the safety
the the legislature uh approved and the
governor is signed an enhancement to the
the workforce violence commissions
um
membership and the ability of them to
ensure the participation of those on the
commission so so the legislature when we
reviewed the workforce violence issue we
determined that it was important to uh
to go ahead because this is an ongoing
problem from our perspective to to
enhance the ability of the community the
hospitals to to to do what they can to
identify it and to ameliorate it was
that SB 459 or something else I I I'm
horrible with Bill numbers it was
Laurie minahan thank you
I know that all right thank you Laurie
and Rory for coming up and making your
presentation and giving us a nice
following up on Senate Bill 292 of 2019
and you will report on the
implementation of New Hampshire's
10-year Mental Health Plan and we have a
handout on that I believe and this will
as Jerry Seinfeld would say not that
so good morning uh this is
um
a privilege to be before you and provide
this update I'm Katya Fox I'm the
director of the division for Behavioral
Health
and good morning I'm Julianne carbon the
director for the Bureau of Mental Health
Services
and what we want to do this morning is
we want to pull out some highlights of
areas that have had significant progress
in the last year and as we do that we
think about the 10-year plan we are
three and a half years into the plan
just about
and as part of that the legislation the
law contemplates us doing reviews
periodic reviews that we just don't come
in here annually and say Here's Where We
Are you know here's here's our progress
but that we as a department and we as a
state look at that plan and see what is
still relevant and what we may have
missed so the environment as you know
has changed in the last three and a half
years we expect further change and so
we're currently undergoing that review
we've been talking and engaging with
stakeholders and are looking forward to
being able to report out on what has
been identified either as a gap or an
area that is doing really well and needs
more infusion of resources and also to
look at what what didn't uh
pan out so we're undergoing that and the
full report is forthcoming and so again
we're going to go we just pulled out
some highlights you have the handout but
we wanted to be succinct and my parking
meter runs out in a little bit so we'll
get through this and be happy to
okay so again a few of the highlights
from from the last year include the
transformation of our crisis response
system as many of you are aware we
launched New Hampshire rapid response
that went live Statewide on January 1st
and it includes those three components
the first is the centralized access
point that provides
um support assessment and triage via
phone text and chat functionalities and
then the ability to deploy mobile
response teams into the community this
this system was really built to address
the needs of children youth adults and
families who are experiencing mental
health or a substance use crisis
and it's quite remarkable actually in in
the last six months more than 16 000
people around the state have made
contact with our access point and that
has result resulted in more than 4 000
community-based deployments
um so we are continuing to work with our
partners and the system has integrated
with the launch of 988 which took place
nationally in in July
the department has also made some
significant progress in expanding our
community-based services and housing
supports for both adults and children
and families and a few of the highlights
from the last year include expansion of
our fast forward program this program
really is designed to provide intensive
wraparound services for children youth
and families who are experiencing
challenges with day-to-day life due to
Serious emotional and disturbances in
their families and and it really serves
Children and Youth who are at risk for
acute psychiatric hospitalization or
Residential Treatment Services again as
as we indicated that program has seen
significant growth in the last year
alone we've had an approximately 23
percent increase in enrollment of
families in the program
in terms of supported housing the
department did increase our rates our
per diem supported housing rates by
approximately 88 in the last year in an
effort to better support providers to
we did contract within last year to
expand supported housing programs in
each of the regions to implement six new
beds and as of today we you know each of
those programs have been working really
hard to identify locations and Staffing
to get those programs up and running and
we have 20 of the 60 beds open and
occupied today which we see as a
significant process progress given given
the environment that we're working
Within
lastly a significant community-based
support that we were able to launch is
our critical time intervention or CTI
that was made available Statewide as of
this past July and CTI is an
evidence-based program that supports
people through their transition from
inpatient
inpatient care into the community it
provides short-term really intensive
Support Services with the intention of
reducing readmissions to an inpatient
hospital so those are just a few of the
community-based services that we've
really seen some significant growth in
the last year
and uh you heard earlier from our Deputy
Commissioner on the update of Hampstead
obviously that was a very significant
undertaking and part of our 10-year plan
and our vision for the mental health
system in the state the last one that I
wanted to pull out and mention is the
IMD waiver for mental health this is
something that we have worked we've had
substance use disorder waiver from the
federal government and we added mental
health beds to this waiver as well and
that we've worked with our federal
partner CMS on establishing that and
what does that do that allows us to be
able to have a Medicaid reimbursement
for beds in facilities that are over 16
beds and so we made some significant
progress on that and that
also is in the process right now of we
have to re it's along Henry can explain
it better but it expires so it only has
a certain amount of time so we have
mended the substance use disorder IMD
waiver and with the mental health
component and now it's going to be up
for Renewal next year so we've already
started that process of the extension
under the request and one of the
exciting things that happened as a
result of this is that we are working
with the Department of Corrections and
adding a piece and requesting that there
be discrete Services care coordination
services for a community re-entry
program where we can have that care
coordination reimbursed and this is for
individuals 45 up to 45 days before they
are returning to the community and it's
not a full-blown Medicaid benefit for 45
days prior to release it's really
focused on that coordination of services
and getting someone ready to be able to
return to the community and be
successful
and so that's that concludes our remarks
I do want to recognize everyone who has
been involved in this process there have
been policy makers there have been
Community leaders Advocates individuals
who've been impacted by mental health
and all of our providers who've really
made this work and be successful and
serve thousands of people across the
state however we know that we continue
to have a lot of work to do and we look
forward to being able to talk about that
and demonstrating
similar progress
I'm going forward
any questions from committee members
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair
um so on recommendation four I think
this is probably where you were talking
about the mobile Vans and the the pack
that we've touched 16 000 people is that
is that correct yes okay so because
um I I am not good with Bill numbers uh
in the in the future if we put a like a
Senate bill 14 could we add the year
that it was passed because that number
is going to be reused right absolutely
you're absolutely right and and so if if
we can make it even simpler by if we're
talking about the mobile van maybe put
the word mobile van in there and it'll
just be easier to do a quick read on
this well in in to be fair though under
that it's a whole array of services
um under the children's system of care
so um so you but Point well taken oh
okay and and the reason I'm I'm I'm
sticking my finger in the mobile van one
is because I've put a few requests out
to get a summary of all of the Vans
because it feels to me like we have
funded Vans under different line items
in the budget and I just want to at some
point maybe in the budget process in
February get a comprehensive review of
all of the mobile Vans and and all of
the metrics that you guys are
accumulating it's a super concept it's
been fun funding this but I just would
like to make sure we get a good program
review absolutely and just from a
deployment and the implementation they
aren't physical Vans necessarily I think
a couple programs have bands but because
of the nature of this they don't know
what community they're responding to and
so they're on call and then and then
respond individually they are mobile
however they very idea being that
individuals and families are served in
their communities we do have statistics
we're talking about that yesterday and
we have handouts that we have that
address the cumulative effect but I want
we're starting to talk about we need to
see where the deployments are happening
where are the calls coming from we do
know a little bit about the deployments
and whether it's children and adults but
we have such Rich data that we need to
start Mining and we know that we want to
share that with you through the budget
process
next is plan for dental care and for
and our friend Henry lippman
and our other friend Dr Sarah Finney
I was thinking of changing my name to
Lori but I think my parents would be
helpful I actually knew an
l-a-u-r-i-e masculine spelling of but
good morning
um for the record Henry lippman State's
Medicaid director
and Dr Sarah Finney the Medicaid dental
director
so I guess as a starting point I think
in terms of the expectations of standing
up the dental program for April 1st that
we've made significant progress and I'm
gonna let Dr Finney walk you through the
one-page handout that hopefully you have
a little too
and representative Edwards I gave you
two copies you probably did
um
all right so I'm taking it from the top
uh we
uh we're required to post a request for
information or RFI by August and we met
that deadline and actually posted the
RFI July 11th the answers were due back
in
um rather quickly we followed up with
the request for proposals after that
which has been posted as of August 25th
and the responses for that are due at
the end of September on the 30th
you know we realized that we have a very
tight timeline to go through all of this
and we're really condensing everything
as much as possible
we'll be spending the time between
September and January working on our
rules development and approval
as well as working on
the Contracting process so that we can
make a presentation at governor and
Council towards the end of October
November early December depending on how
the Contracting process proceeds
we are currently working on all of the
paperwork that we have to submit to CMS
so our state plan Amendment the waivers
that we need to file
um and on various other paperwork with
them is in process and we're going back
and forth in conversation with CMS so
that we have all of that completed in
time as Henry already said April 1st is
our implementation date and we are
standing by that and working to make
sure that that occurs
according to the final legislation that
was signed into law the department will
be presenting an annual report to this
committee to give an update on how the
process of implementation went how the
utilization is being managed and various
other indicators of progress and success
with the program
I've given you the links you also should
have received an electronic copy of this
but the links are here to the RFI and
the RFP should you want to go and take a
look at all of the documents that are
attached to those and then the last link
at the bottom of the page takes you
directly to the signed legislation if
you want to refer back to exactly what
was included in that so I don't know if
representative soloway Mr lippman Dr
Finney uh this is just wonderful to hear
please forgive my impatience do you have
any notion of what the response is
you know how many bidders you might get
whether anybody's talked to you about
we're planning on submitting your
proposal
and I beg of you forgive my impatience
I think we probably can leave it that we
have at participants
um in both the RFI process and that it's
we ask for letters of intent but it's
not a requirement one thing I would
um that we posted is that you know the
model that is in the RFP is a model of a
dental organization
um meaning that it will be a standalone
outside of the current Managed Care
organizations but the Managed Care
organizations who have dental arms can
bid on that as well
so we're hoping for a good responses I
guess is what
I had breakfast with uh Thomas Raphael
recently and we amazingly discussed
dental care and I raised the question a
bill is as good as the number of
dentists who are willing to do this and
he and I expressed concern and we also
expressed as a follow-up
what practical things can we do to
encourage more dentists
and more dentists to participate and I'm
leaving that as an open question worthy
of exploration not that you haven't
thought of it
I I would just comment uh briefly that
there are two aspects in the bill that
that address that one is that the
financing of it allowed for a rate
increase to bring our rates up more
normative to what's expected in Medicaid
um and then secondly the the care
coordination and transportation
component to make sure that if a dentist
is willing to see a patient that the
chair actually gets an appointment
and I I would just add to that that
um we have a number of Advocates across
the state who realize the importance of
having an adequate provider Network and
they are addressing that you know from
their particular Viewpoint so I think
that there's a number of ways that that
message is being
um sent to our dental providers and
hopefully they will listen and respond
is there any are there any plans afoot
oh to do loan forgiveness for a dentist
who will resettle to this area for X
number of years and we'll take X number
of Medicaid patients at as a matter of
fact we made a significant change to the
student loan repayment program that the
state has which we lovingly refer to as
slurp and we now have several different
mechanisms for dentists to enter that
program and we are doing that in an
effort to try to keep to bring dentists
to the state and also keep them here
do you have any demographics on dentists
who
um
are participating presently in terms of
age my fear is that some of them may be
uh that we we do it's it's an
ever-changing thing
um one of the interesting things that
occurred with over the last several
years is that we had some Advanced uh
speed of retirement and then some folks
actually deciding to come back into
practice so I'd say we're you know
there's an in and out uh but we are
constantly watching
um you know where our numbers are
another there's there's two other things
that I do want to
um let you know uh besides the student
loan repayment we do have the department
has a contract to do
um recruiting of dentists through some
assistance from Bi-State Primary Care
Association so this is another way that
we're reaching out to dental students
and
um general practice residency graduates
to try to encourage them to come to the
state and then the other thing which
will be happening next summer we will
have our first group of general practice
residency dentists in the state which
have not been here for the last 10 to 15
years and that is another mechanism
where they rotate through locations in
the state and hopefully we will retain
them here once they finish their program
would would you take that part of your
presentation which addresses my question
on what are you doing to get more
dentists in and make it email to us
because this is a keeper okay any other
questions for Mr Lipman and Dr Finney
representative Edwards
um so I I think this is a great program
uh the only part that causes me to lose
any sleep at night I mean the Manpower
is certainly a key piece but but I
um the the fact that we got verbal
approvals on the two CMS waivers
still leaves me uncertain that when we
file the official paperwork that we're
going to get formal approvals of our
waiver requests and so is is this an
irrational fear on my part or do I need
to quit worrying about CMS approving our
waivers you think that's what that's
what my job is is to worry about all
that and and Henry I just want to let
you know I'm helping you with the
worrying part
I think we're very confident
um based on our interactions that we're
going to get there as with any state
plan Amendment sometimes takes us quite
a few exchanges of How It's worded to
get to where we want to go but I think
in terms of the the clear policy issues
that you wanted to address when you
drafted the provisions that were
comfortable those are uh statutory and
Regulatory within the bounds of which
standing with them that they are
reviewing to be you know just to make
sure that the teaser crossed eyes dotted
and and whatnot so that is an ongoing
representative McMahon thank you Mr
chairman
um Ms Ms Finney and Mr lippen uh
relative to
the timeline for implementation that
states here at table first but they then
there will be an annual report and
knowing that we deal with with the
budgets as
I would have been alluded to coming up
very very quickly what's the date then
of the annual report
uh based on the implementation starting
April April 1st of next year I believe
it was um to be a yearly report so we
would want to be one year in so
April 1st of 24
because we need to have some
important functioning of the the plan to
be able to report to you and as far as
the funding goes
um this benefit was funded with the sun
teen settlement funds and so we are
covered for the next biennium budget for
this benefit with those funds and just
follow up its General follow-up uh
understanding that the sentine
settlement is not in perpetuity I uh in
all seriousness was looking here from a
planning going uh going forward
well the
um in the annual report have that
functional cost benefit
uh analysis to show the cost savings and
that in time for when CMS does their
review of approving the waiver each time
that's
um does that meet their timeline so we
don't have that battle during budget
time
I think that
um we're we're prepared to report on a
frequency basis that exceeds what was
required in statute so
um in terms of keeping this committee
informed you were very helpful to
advancing the benefit and couldn't have
done it without you and so we want to
make sure that we're giving you the
information so that
you have what you need to advocate for
the continuation of the benefit past the
the funding that we already have so
um we're going to make sure that you're
getting what you need to to do that for
us we appreciate appreciate that and
just to clarify so that's in the
commitment I mean just so I can be
counted when needed you can count that
as a commitment sir yeah it'll be done
to ensure that we're complying with a
CMS
adjustment of criteria not only CMS but
just in terms of what the expectations
around what the benefit costs and and
what we would be providing for it um you
know I think the workforce challenge is
probably it extends into the dental
practice Arena as well and you know I
think that probably our primary concern
is even if we have good access in terms
of contractually in terms of what are
the wait times due to the Staffing
that's available in in dentist office
but you know we'll we'll keep you
apprised of that as well thank you sir
thank you
thank you so much
and finally the DD and ABD wait list
good afternoon thank you for having us
this morning I'm Melissa Hardy I am the
director for the division of long-term
hi I'm Sandy farrows the bureau chief at
the Bureau of Developmental services
for those looking at the agenda you're
listed as Sandy furrows yes yes just
make sure thank you
I knew that but I
appreciate that we are here to give an
update on the home and community-based
Care waivers which allow us to support
people with developmental disabilities
and acquired brain disorder in the
community
we're reporting through June 30th which
is the end of fiscal year 22 and I'm
happy to report that we were able to
identify funding and allocate funding to
797 individuals for fiscal year
69 of those individuals are people that
required additional services
26 of those people were new and aging
into the system and five percent are
people that were brand new to servicing
and they were
coming in from out of state or maybe
losing resources that they may have had
previously
so for those individuals that were
allocated funding I know that one of the
questions was around whether or not
people were able to actually start
services and we were able to identify
that 71 percent did start
29 percent are waiting on identifying
services and for those that haven't
started their services the consistent
issue which we've talked about a lot
this morning has to do with the
workforce shortage and
staff and provider Recruitment and
identification identification of an
agency that can provide the services
so that's consistent across both
populations the developmental
disabilities population as well as
people with acquired acquired brain
disorder
so for the In-Home Support waiver which
specifically supports children with
developmental disabilities we were able
to allocate funding for 69 children in
state fiscal year 22.
86 percent of those were Aging in new to
services and 14 were receiving enhanced
services
of those individuals that received the
allocated funding 82 percent were able
to begin services
and these are the students that that
leave school and then receive services
in their communities
18 percent
are waiting for services and again the
same issue around Workforce
is for that population as well and then
for finally for acquired brain disorder
for State fiscal year 22 we identified
funding for 44 people
and again 89 percent
um oh excuse me 67 percent
receive services and 33 of that
population are waiting for their
services to begin
so those are our numbers in terms of
people that were allocated funding on
all three waivers and
I would say the people waiting for
services are consistent with our last
report about 20 percent
waiting for services to begin for the DD
population and the ABD
any questions
on the wait list
under McMahon thank you Mr chairman
and is it MS furos
yes Ms pharaohs is fine I want to make
sure I pronounce it correctly uh
um relative to those who are waiting uh
one of the main criteria was rates of
pay not getting enough uh
Professional Services to step up in this
regard is that still the case that
you're finding uh or or not at this
point yes we hear that often from
providers and from agencies
follow up that being said and I've been
doing my own talk about it to say where
do we need to be based on enhancing and
the uh attractiveness of this very
important job is one way to pay would
you be recommending or have you
discussed to
entice the professionals to take these
positions that ultimately save the state
literally millions of dollars in the
aggregate by home and community-based
care
so what's the rate of pay that we need
to consider going forward
the rate of pay varies across provider
agencies and area agencies and of course
there are other things to consider like
benefit packages and things that
providers have been able to identify one
of the challenges is that we don't have
a an updated rate methodology and we are
currently undergoing
um
a data collection process also known as
the cost survey where we within the
bureau are working closely with our
agencies to identify the cost of
delivering services so that we can
contribute to a new rate methodology and
that I'm optimistic that that will help
give providers a rate that's appropriate
so that they can reimburse their
Workforce
and just in closing will that be done
while we're young
get it done while we're young yes
no I'm not old I'm aggressively mature
but I'm just looking here as this that's
been discussed quite a bit in all
seriousness it has can that be a not can
be is it not a Target to have it done
this year because of this critical uh
accessibility for for Workforce growth
the target for the closure of that data
collection is November of this year so
once we have the data we'll be able to
work with our rate setting vendor and
our actuary to start looking at their
recommendation and that would be ready
for the budget consideration
for the next two-year budget cycle yes
that's what we're hoping
you're hoping or committed to
but now it's seriousness yeah I would
have to I would have to
um I'm not sure it depends on the data
that comes back but we would like to
have that for the next budget cycle for
sure all right and my last thing on that
ultimately is Asap November 1st or
November 30th
first okay thank you very much you're
welcome
I just wanted to add um we also you know
recognize and understand the workforce
shortage but we have also provided
um over 20 million dollars to our area
agencies for Staffing recruiting
retention and training bonuses the
one-time arpa money
um to hopefully enhance
um one-time money for people to come
into the workforce but we understand you
know that people are looking for a
long-term plan to find folks to do the
work but we we have looked at those
opportunities and funding streams
yeah
population is dear to my heart for a
number of reasons and I've tried to
facilitate a coming together between the
department and the families of people in
need over the issue of the redesign
my policy committee loves to square
circles we love to vote things out
unanimously we don't every time get
everybody happy but we lessen the mildly
annoyed level as much as we can and
could you give me an update on how this
is uh unfolding yes so um thank you for
that I like that mildly annoyed we'll
Target for that but certainly um just a
brief update for our stakeholder
engagement we do have ongoing meetings
with our stakeholders so those would be
our providers our area agencies
individuals and families
um that that that support the
developmental disability community so
monthly we have
um stakeholder stakeholder work group
meetings we have an advisory committee a
waiver committee looking and providing
input on the the redesign of the waivers
waiver
we have our rates committee and also a
committee on communication
assessment so we have we've had
um to date nearly over 50 different
meetings as it relates to those advisory
committees
we've held earlier this summer 10
Regional in person forums in different
locations for individuals and families
to be able to talk to us at The Bureau
about the redesign answer questions have
information out there so we're planning
on doing another round of those
in-person meetings targeting individuals
and families starting in October so us
going out into the community also having
a virtual option for those meetings as
well for folks that can't make it in
person but really find that you know
talking to the individuals and families
that receive service and you know truly
provide a lot of the services in the
community is really helpful for us for
feedback
we also in September
um released our first BDS newsletter
which went extensively over the redesign
process based on the feedback from our
family meetings so did you send me one I
did would you send me another one I get
300 emails a day thank you absolutely
um so that went out earlier this month
and we proposed we're going to continue
that on a quarterly basis just as a
standard communication not necessarily
focused just on the redesign but
information from the bureau as a whole
as well
uh we also
um have
um our consultant and Sandy have gone
out to some of the the sites talking to
the era agencies and providers and into
individuals and families
um going out to them and listening to
them as well we have some information
sections virtually that I believe you
participated in recently so we have
those as well for individuals and
Families
um and certainly working with the
community supports Network on on a
regular basis which is the Trade
Organization for the area agencies
talking with them on a routine basis as
well so that's some of our stakeholder
engagement but certainly open to
anyone's suggestions for for further
engagement
my question would be and it's a compound
question
because of this process and because of
your
really doing extra amount of Engagement
do you can you say that
in some way or other your
redesign has been modified and can you
say in some degree the stakeholder
upsettedness has been mollified so
that's modified modified that was pretty
clever but are you coming to better
place do you in your opinion yes and I
hope it does continue to to get better
um a good example of that is from our
advisory committee we had a direct
support professional subcommittee Who
provided the department with
recommendations on how we move forward
with the DSP Workforce and so we Sandy
just held a advisory committee yesterday
to review those recommendations for the
subcommittee and getting the advisory
committee's feedback on how we proceed
with those recommendations
also in the original redesign there was
talk about a two two waiver service
So based on the feedback from our
stakeholders and committees we put the
development of that second waiver on
pause so we can work
um you know at our developing and
refining our developmental disabilities
waiver and focusing on the work that
needs to get done
my ear to the ground except for people
who get up in the morning looking for
reasons to be angry
and they exist
my sense is there is appreciation of
your listening and there is in many
people a willingness to come this way
because they see you're coming this way
I I'm going to say let's let's continue
this but I'm happy to see progress right
thank you so much for the feedback
you're welcome
anything else representative Edwards
yeah hi I I would uh like to talk about
the same thing I talk about every time
which is the visual information provided
and I I love the fact that you are
talking in terms of percentages of you
know who's being seen and who we're
having some issues with but I I just
need to take issue with the handout as
written
um I I think we've talked about this
before but I I wasn't very specific
where it says developmental disabilities
wait list
this is not a wait list this is uh as I
understand it a statistical summary of
funding shortages
and so like when we look at the right
side of the graph there are zero funding
shortages but there are in fact a
waiting list for reasons that we can't
control but there is a wait list out
there so so I'm concerned that the way
this is headed it is subject to having
the public misinterpret it and I just
want some element of transparency I
would like our visual information to be
uh precise but do you have a comment on
that
um yeah I would say what was provided
exactly what you said it's it shows that
everyone has been funded for services
not necessarily that as Sandy said
receiving services so we can work on
that visual for you okay so that's a
simple one that's just changing the two
uses of the word wait list to funding
shortage or or something that you think
is more appropriate but and then the
have you all been able to conceptualize
a graphical way of representing these
percentages that are causing us to have
a real wait list
you know what what what the causes are
for maybe I just got handed the what I'm
exactly asking about
so what's what's being handed out now is
just a graphic representation of the
percentages that that I shared with you
and we're not sure if this would be
helpful or if it would be desired but if
this is to your liking we can continue
presenting this representative um you'll
see DD waiver in-home supports waiver
and ABD waiver all on their own page
there's a pie chart that represents the
number of people receiving Services
keeping in mind the people receiving
Services may be partial so somebody
might require three and maybe they're
getting one out of three so keeping that
in mind
um and then the Orange is not receiving
services at all we included the numbers
of people that were projected to start
for that entire pie chart as well as the
top delay reasons and this is again for
the fiscal year all right so so I'll
I'll thank you for this I I won't put
myself in a position to critique whether
or not this is the right uh visual way
of laying this out I think as you play
with it more you'll get used to it and
maybe you'll have some ideas on the way
you may want to enhance it or change it
a little bit I I would just throw my
caution in there though that don't over
respond to what I'm saying I mean
there's a value-added trade-off if you
find yourself spending too much time
chasing a pretty picture or a graphic
and and not enough time getting care to
patients then then we're doing it wrong
so I I do like the communication to the
public so thank you for that and if we
could just make that part of the
quarterly report Mr chair would that be
a bit possible that would be possible
do you all have an issue with making the
this nice graphic uh part of the
quarterly report yes certainly we can
yes all right thank you and and I do
thank you this is this is nice this
feels
it's actually kind of nice to be able to
make an observation and say something
and actually seeing something happen so
in under a minute so thank you yes
so I look forward to your sending me
that again and if I can add business
cards from both of you and thank you so
much our next meeting
okay
one question uh specific to this and I'm
going back on a long time being involved
with this uh the expression of the DD
waitlist was uh always based on funding
only and not access to Services now
looking at this as representative
Edwards is speaking with as well is to
make this part of the program is uh IEPs
versus ISP services and the values
they're from
would always still remain as part of the
the wait list which is the funding
criteria there wouldn't be a quite a
waiting for dollars but it's these like
we have three criteria vendor family or
recruitment uh in here is those uh
individual costs of would be specific
uh to still meeting the funding would
still be there it's just the physical
delivery of the said service not being
there correct so I just want to make
sure that we're not going to go back in
time and always have a funding debate
and then it's a value judgment year fund
buying trees or funding human human
beings needs right I would say be even
more intentional perhaps in contrasting
those two things this statistic is
because of lack of funding this
statistic is because we've got the
funding but we can't find the troops
that make it even more explicit would be
my suggestion just that's I was just
going to assure representative McMahon
that
um I I in no way want to lose sight of
Our obligation to properly fund this I
I'm just looking at words and and
precision of what they mean and and when
I hear wait list I'm I'm thinking you
know patients standing out in line
somewhere not being seen not whether or
not we've done our job to fund it that's
and I and I don't know if we have to
like
tweak along or ignore a law to to get
the terminology a little crisper well if
I may offer I know your point your point
is well taken which is why I wanted to
have from the authorities having
jurisdiction right here their guidance
as well is it has was always uh let me
say always the with the precursor of
today was always uh a funding issue not
an accessibility of service issue uh
that that being moot right now based on
the last four reports here that you know
going back now two three years uh it is
coming more to the service end of it and
then when we can focus then as a
committee then we're going to know we're
gonna have the same language when we're
talking to our families to say what's
the issue here the state has met its
Challenge on funding and commitment to
to for home and community-based care
this is another challenge and dealing
with Professionals of where do we locate
such Services which may not be in the
state of New Hampshire and that's then
those challenges will be will be met but
it takes Cooperative collaboration to
achieve consensus on how to do it so I
just uh that's what I wanted to clarify
you have the same language and not have
to go back to class again the next time
you're here but I thank you very much
and thank you and with that we will be
meeting again on Friday October 28th you
foreign
I didn't say I'd fund it